Despite the MCU's raging success at adapting
their library of comic book stories to film,
not every one of their storylines is well-suited
to the silver screen.
Some stories are too violent.
Some are simply too controversial, or carry
unsettling undertones.
And a few are just too dang weird for a mainstream
movie studio.
Whatever the cause, don't expect to see these
tales unfold in the theater until everyone's
run entirely out of ideas—and even then,
don't hold your breath.
The Ultimates
The Avengers borrows a lot from The Ultimates:
superheroes bickering among themselves, the
Hulk going on a rampage, and a largescale
alien invasion forcing the team to put their
differences aside and come together to save
the Earth are all part of the iconic story.
And then there's the fact that MCU Nick Fury
is a dead-on duplicate of Ultimate Nick Fury.
So far, so good… but that's about as adaptable
as the Ultimates saga gets.
The Ultimates presents a very cynical view
of superheroes.
Ultimate Captain America is a xenophobe.
Ultimate Hank Pym brutally beats his wife.
Ultimate Hulk just straight-up eats people.
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver—brother and
sister—are lovers.
Things reach an insane crescendo when the
X-Men villain the Blob eats the Wasp, and
Hank Pym responds in kind, using his size-changing
abilities to get revenge by biting Blob's
head off.
Most of the X-Men perish, Thing crushes Doctor
Doom's head with his bare hands, and Manhattan
is more or less annihilated.
It goes without saying that the whole story
is too dour for mainstream Marvel to put on
the screen.
People like to root for their heroes; The
Ultimates makes that more or less impossible.
Secret Empire
You might've heard about the controversial
premise of Secret Empire, even if you're not
a comic reader.
Yeah, that's right: this is the comic that
makes Captain America a Nazi.
So, technically Cap was a sleeper agent for
HYDRA… except he wasn't really, thanks to
Red Skull and some Cosmic Cube stuff.
But despite Marvel's claims, that doesn't
really make anything better... the basic story
is Steve Rogers infiltrates SHIELD, reveals
his true nature, and conquers America in HYDRA's
name.
Isn't that uplifting?
Even if HYDRA-Cap isn't a Nazi by name, the
parallels are too strong to ignore.
Because, you know, HYDRA is basically Nazis.
Hail HYDRA
We've already had two HYDRA-fueled takeovers
of America in the MCU already, a third - led
by Nazi Cap - it's pretty unlikely.
These days, real-life Nazis—some of whom
proudly wear Captain America's gear—are
an actual problem.
Because of this, Secret Empire received plenty
of criticism from the comic book community.
Marvel's not going to court that kind of controversy
by repeating the plot in theaters, and won't
risk tainting one of its most popular characters
for a stunt.
Count on it.
Sins Past
The Green Goblin might be Spider-Man's arch-nemesis,
but don't expect Norman Osborn to grace theater
screens any time soon.
For the Goblin's diehard fans, that's bad
news, but there's one silver lining.
Norman's absence means there's no way that
Spider-Man's "Sins Past" story arc will ever
get a big-screen adaptation, and that's very,
very good.
"Sins Past" sees Peter Parker's girlfriend
Gwen Stacy have a brief fling with Norman,
the guy who eventually ends her life, while
vacationing in France.
As a result of the encounter, Gwen gives birth
to twins.
It's not only the age difference between Gwen
and Norman that makes the story so bad.
It's not only that Mary Jane knew about the
affair and didn't tell Peter until the twins
appear at his door.
No, it's that in the follow-up storyline,
"Sins Remembered," Peter makes out with one
of the twins because she kind of looks like
Gwen.
Kissing the daughter of your long-lost love
and number one villain while you're married
to someone else?
That's bad.
Comic book readers didn't tolerate it, and
eventually, the whole affair was retconned
out of existence.
Chances are, movie audiences wouldn't tolerate
it, either.
Thor: Vikings
Not even Chris Hemsworth's dreamy smile and
strong sense of humor could make Thor: Vikings
work onscreen.
As this dark superhero adventure reminds us,
the ancient Norsemen weren't wisecracking
swashbucklers like Thor and his comrades.
They were hardened warriors with a mean streak
a mile long, which Thor: Vikings revels in.
This is the comic that opens with a Viking
horde razing a Norwegian village, and then
sends the invaders to modern day New York,
where they pillage and slay their way through
Manhattan as undead conquerors.
They drive a spear through the mayor on live
television.
They block the streets with piles of severed
heads.
Even Thor has trouble stopping them, especially
after they snap both of the thunder god's
arms, chain his hammer to his neck, and chuck
him into the Hudson river.
The differences between the violent, unforgiving
nature of real-life Vikings and colorful,
successful fare like Thor: Ragnarok are too
great.
Even if it weren't, Thor: Vikings is just
too violent for mainstream moviegoers.
Even dedicated gore-hounds might find some
of the gruesome antics stomach-turning.
"That's a nice way of putting it."
Deadpool: Killustrated
Deadpool isn't an entirely bad guy, but he's
also got no problem with violence.
He's a mercenary in a world full of supervillains,
so sometimes, gore is going to happen.
It's just part of the job.
That's why he's so popular.
But there's still a line, and Deadpool's been
known to cross it.
Not only has he obliterated every hero in
the Marvel Universe—twice—but in Deadpool:
Killustrated, the Merc with a Mouth hunts
down characters from pieces of classic literature.
And yeah, it's kind of funny to watch Wade
Wilson scoop out Don Quixote's eyeballs, spread
Tom Sawyer's blood all over the boy's newly
painted fence, and torch Dracula.
It's also very, very dark, even for Deadpool.
On the page, Deadpool's violence doesn't seem
any worse than a particularly depraved cartoon.
Translate that story into live action, however,
and the murder of everyone in The Jungle Book
would be positively traumatic.
JLA/Avengers
The Avengers proved that superhero crossovers
could work just as well in theaters as they
do in comic shops.
But, these days, interconnected superhero
universes are old news.
In fact, there's only one big superhero crossover
left to do, but it'll never happen.
Letting DC and Marvel characters share the
same screen would be like the USS Enterprise
dogfighting with the Millennium Falcon.
The corporate overlords at Disney and Warner
Bros. won't ever agree to it, even if fans
would literally rip off their own arms to
see it happen.
That's a shame, too, because comic books have
already given both studios the perfect template
for a blockbuster.
JLA/Avengers tells the story of an epic clash
between Earth's mightiest heroes and the League,
who duke it out before teaming up to stop
a timeless evil.
JLA/Avengers could be the superhero movie
to end all superhero movies.
But it won't be.
Not only would the rights be a nightmare to
untangle, but after a team-up like that, there's
nowhere to go but down.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!